Republicans including former president
Trump are throwing their full support
behind Georgia Senate candidate Herschel
Walker despite a report in The Daily
Beast claiming he paid for a
girlfriend's abortion in 2009. Walker
denies all of that and he prayed
yesterday with a supportive crowd at a
surprise campaign event as he remains
locked in a very close race with
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock Robert
Costas following this in Atlanta Bob
good morning what's the reaction been in
Georgia to all of this
good morning Nate nationally Republicans
are standing with Walker that shows how
important this race is to winning the
Senate majority here in Georgia it's
mostly the same conservative activist
Eric Erickson told us the next 48 hours
will be critical for Walker's campaign
in terms of how he answers tough
questions Democrats expect the race
against incumbent Democratic senator
Raphael Warnock to Titan
Bob uh Walker's son Christian who was
known as a conservative influencer
posted this video on Twitter after his
dad denied the abortion allegations I
want you to take a look
he has four kids four different women
wasn't in the house raising one of them
he was out having sex with other women
do you care about family values
I have a silent line of July after life
the abortion car drops yesterday it's
literally his handwriting in the car
they say they have receipts whatever he
gets on Twitter he lies about it
these are strong words by his own son
Bob has the campaign responded to
Christian's remarks
Herschel Walker has said he loves his
son a 23 year old who at times has been
a controversial social media figure but
this entire episode and these clips
really shows how in politics today
family Dynamics can erupt at times on
social media and it's become not just a
political Reckoning for Herschel Walker
but a personal one because these videos
have generated over a million views
online Nate
my eyes will be on this race for more
reasons than one Bob thank you